I was thinking about you you're really
good actress right you do your thing
when you see like a Emma Stone who's got
like a similar look to you or let's say
Jessica Chastain I can tell you've
thought about this like when you see
some of those movies don't you sit there
girl I can [ __ ] do those yes right
yes gotta be driving you nuts I know
what is I think is I don't live in LA
and people still are stuck in this old
idea because of your rehab days and all
that one sent me a link and this only
happens to me when I'm in the u.s.
someone sent me a link to TMZ then it
was on last night and I was in bed and
they were so nice to me oh I was like
whoa oh my god thank you yeah you're
shocked when people are nice to you I
mean when you think about your career
with the amount of money or movies have
made and people love you you know I mean
let's face it it's gotta be a huge
adjustment even to live in you know
Mykonos or wherever I don't even know
where these places are you know I know
there's like Greece or something yeah
yeah what do I know I don't even let the
United States I don't know where Greece
is I don't know how to get there you
lived it and then you go over to Dubai
and like you just fly over and for not
far like ya know that's a lot of work
and you live by yourself well rent like
a small place my mom came on this year
before the show Oh see you're on you're
on good terms of your mom yeah she came
to stay with me and then Michael and his
wife came to stay with me who's Michael
your dad no no okay Michael your brother
well they named him Michael Michael do
decoded it right and you're not in touch
with your dad I take it I am oh you are
yeah oh oh everyone's in touch look at
this you know somebody going to Dubai
yeah